well basson Piers it's good to see you
it's good to see you too um last time
obviously we did it remotely yes you
were here I was in London and you
complained that it was an unfair
situation you couldn't see me your
earpiece kept falling out yes so I
thought okay fair enough I hear you I
got on a plane I flew 6 and a half
thousand miles and not only that we're
doing it in somewhere that is very
familiar to you it's The Comedy Store in
Los Angeles where you performed many
times as a standup so I've done my bet
you did you did but actually this not
this not the first time we meet in
person no no we did originally in London
last year and I know that many people
are watching this for the first time I
know this but like I would really love
to tell the story of that moment because
uh I was having a a tour in the UK in
Europe and I was doing my English
standup and one of my uh you know
advertis promotion plan was to come on
your show so my Asian Congress like B
you're going to be be on Peters Morgan I
said damn he like what's wrong it's like
well uh Peters Morgan blocked me on
Twitter I did and he said like what did
you do I said well during January 6th
you know the in Direction you know uh
you tweeted something about it and I was
so angry at what's happening and I
remember you having you and Donald Trump
in a picture and I said said the guy who
had Donald Trump with him whatever and
then I I I used like very harsh words
and of course you block me so I and then
I said like does he know I don't know
does he know I don't know does he know I
don't know so I walked into the studio
and the moment I was like being seated
and they're preparing before we go on
air and you said oh hi Basim it seems
that you have more followers than me but
it seems that I blocked you
why and I told you and then we we said
the story on air and it was funny
because I made a joke I like you have
always been standing against cancel
culture and you just canceled me on the
but we agreed that this is not canceling
because this is your own space and
you're free but now you're unblocked me
and we are and we're here and we here
and it was yeah and actually we agreed
about January the 6th by the way just
for the record um the I was don't about
you maybe you weren't surprised I was
completely staggered by the response
globally to our interview several weeks
ago were you taken back by the scale of
it uh yes of course but I understand why
um for many years the media covering the
Middle East has uh been um showing a
certain point of view I'm not going to
say bias but I would say it did not
allow certain voices certain um voices
from the other side to be heard and that
is why you see the frustration you all
whenever you speak to people in the
Middle East they tell you the same thing
uh they they they not very happy with
the the coverage because our voices are
not heard now I am the least qualified
person ever to talk about this conflict
and yet just because I relate some of of
the talking points that we say and we
hear the whole time people felt hurt and
when you when people have this feeling
they they're happy they are they have
this response they said oh my God for
the for the first time the West are
actually hearing our point of view some
of the point of view might not be go
well with other people but at least we
have a conversation and I think that is
the reason why people reacted that way
yeah it's it's such an incendiary
subject matter I've never seen social
media so Ablaze with hostility on on
both sides did you actually as well as
enormous praise from the Arab world did
you also get criticized by some parts of
the Arab world for not going perhaps
hard enough oh you didn't do that you
didn't do that thing is this is like uh
you're damn if you do you're damn if you
not right if you don't speak up why
don't you speak up if you speak up you
didn't speak up if you're done why are
you if you speak up too much oh you're
taking all the attention on you and I I
love that fact because people people
always who accuse people of being the
center of attention they are actually
not very happy that the attention is not
on them this is actually like a rule on
social media but yeah there was a
backlash but there's also a backlash
from the other side which um I I mean
here and other comedy clubs I worked
with people from all kind of different
backgrounds Jewish Christians Muslims
Arabs atheists all kinds of people and
there are a lot of people who went to my
S like oh so you're a terrorist
sympathizer now you know and uh I think
it is important to have uh a
nuanced deep interesting intelligent
conversation a lot of people waiting for
this are kind yeah B Barry Pierce show
him and this is the problem with the
news today the problem is the news today
it's not about the news anymore it's
about the people giving you the news so
it becomes a show a circus two
Gladiators in the
Coliseum two pigs fighting the mud and
this is why people don't get anything
out of it it's a circus you know one of
the things I heard a lot was who is this
guy and they weren't talking about me
sometimes sometimes I want now obviously
you're very very well known in the Arab
you're known as the kind of they called
you the Arab John Stewart and you're
well known in America but you weren't
that well known for example in the UK uh
and I think what this interview did it
made a lot of people think wow all right
this this is incredible but tell me more
about Bassam MF and I I did a bit of
research into your life and is a
fascinating Journey that you've gone on
to get here to Los Angeles and I think
it's worth just taking a little beat
here to talk about this because you
began in Cairo as a heart surgeon me
that was your career path yes and and
you were a heart surgeon I was a heart
surgeon until yeah uh I spent 19 years
in that car 7 years in medical school 12
years as a practicing doctor and uh 2011
happened and the revolution happened and
I had my own show on YouTube I did like
small videos well I'm going to come to
this because I was in I by coincidence I
had just joined CNN to replace the great
Larry King and I hadn't actually done
any live show I'd done a few weeks since
I joined of taped interviews with big
names Donald Trump Oprah Winfrey things
like that and I was flying back to Los
Angeles when I got a message that Egypt
was going up in start of the Arab Spring
and I actually went to a studio very
near here about a mile down the road on
sun the CNN studio the old Larry King
studio and I went live for the first
time and it was about the Arab Spring it
was about what was happening in Egypt
and at the same time you in Egypt were
actually in Tera Square helping wounded
protesters actually medically treating
them yeah yeah uh I mean this was a kind
of movement that inspired a lot of
Egyptians um at the time I was you know
I was in the hospital and a lot of
people just volunteered and the Nur like
giving us like supplies go go go and we
were going there and we were basically
tending to the wounded because it is and
and it kind of gives you a different
perspective when you
see helpless defenseless people who do
who are not armed they are being beaten
by Security Forces military forces being
shot being uh you know hurt and uh all
we can do is just like provide some
medical attention and it kind of gives
you a perspective to see how Humanity
sometimes can show its most ugly fa and
the suppression of free speech freedom
of expression yeah the ability of people
to say what they honestly feel about a
situation yes and the suppression of
people's basic rise to Freedom
absolutely yeah and uh that kind of like
taught me a lot and uh and inspired me
to do the show but you know well you
start it's a crazy story this and I I
want to tell it because you just decided
to do five minute stuff on YouTube yeah
and you are expecting a few people to
watch it and then literally it just
flies and suddenly you're getting
millions of people watching this and
very quickly one of the big networks
comes in and then you're suddenly doing
this stuff for 30 to 40 million people
like a third of the entire population of
Egypt is tuning in to watch it you're
the biggest star of Egyptian television
oh please you are don't
stop somebody I mean what an
extraordinary thing though for a heart
surgeon to go from helping protesters
medically into Ria Square the start of
the Arab Spring to within a year you're
the biggest star on Egyptian television
it's a crazy thing it doesn't sound as
glamorous as this it's it feels it it
felt horrible did it why oh yeah
overnight Fame this size it's toxic
terrible terrible it it it's it corrupts
it it it it goes into your soul soul and
it's not good it's not I I I actually
didn't enjoy it uh and the worst the
worst part about is that like you're
trying to do comedy in very
controversial Climate about very
controversial issues so you'll never
never satisfy people and the problem is
that you're people have these
expectations oh if you are successful in
this you must be successful at solving
this and when things are not solved
because Politics as you
know very difficult to solve uh the the
that expectation this love turns into
hate and and and this is and this is one
of many many reasons that I had to leave
and I and I came here eventually well I
want let's just take people through what
happened because they probably don't
know a lot of people so during the
presidency of Muhammad Mory who was a
democratically elected islamist you you
had relative freedom to start but then
the more you went after government
propaganda the more you stood up for the
people against the government then the
trouble started morsy wanted to shut you
up you eventually get dragged through
the courts I was arrested I was arrested
for one day it was a warrant for my
arrest and then I turned myself in and I
was
interrogated and it was the funniest
interrogation ever and in my standup
shows I I I talk about that scene cuz
the gods were reading the stuff out and
laughing right well the guards were
taking selfies with me which is funny
and and the uh and and it the exchange
between me and the inter and persecutor
G persecutor was extremely funny I mean
I don't like to victimize myself I don't
like oh look at that I actually like to
find humor why were you arrested what
was the criteria oh yeah the I I think
the list was insulting Islam insulting
the president spreading false rumors and
disrupting the fabric of society and uh
and it was I think the people in the
room didn't know what to do with me
because they ended up discussing my
jokes so it turned into a writer's room
and I I was kind of like how do you
think we make this funnier and it was
the funniest exchange ever and after six
hours I I was let go and uh was it scary
though at the same time that suddenly
the Machinery was getting a grip of you
because it was to get a lot scarier but
was it in that moment when you first got
arrested you thought I'm being arrested
for breaching my freedom of speech
right for some reason I I I just like
went with the flow I went to the
interrogation wearing the big hat I went
to the show it was it was just I I just
wanted this to be a farce because I I
just like you you're really coming after
the comedian and it it was it I I I just
tried to enjoy myself but deep inside I
was
dying well you actually it gets serious
enough where you may have died because
actually morsy gets of course deposed
incomes General LCC in a coup a military
coup and he doesn't find satar a
laughing matter particularly when the
jokes are about him you get blocked they
literally block your show from
airing I aired one episode and it's
interesting this is this is a very
interesting story because the first
episode that was aired after the removal
in the Muslim Brotherhood everybody was
waiting to see what I will say because
by that time all of the Islamic channels
that were mean like me and me and
Islamic Channel like it's like they had
five channels and they were like me and
them going like that they they had like
five Chan I have only one hour a week
and then they were removed and then a
lot of the other desent voices were also
being shut down now people are waiting
what will Bim say and on the day that
the show aired the next day I went I
went out and everybody's like good good
at least somebody is speaking it was a
very controversial episode nobody liked
it and yet everybody liked it because
people said like you're supporting the
coup no you're the Muslim Brotherhood
everybody accused me of something all I
did in that episode was just being a
mirror of what is happening in the
street and showing them how ridiculous
it is you didn't take your fixed
position well my position depending on
where what's your position what did you
intend your position my my position was
to show the
Ridiculousness of how the people now was
like oh we got rid of Islamic fascism
but we are heading towards another
fascism uh there was and there was a
song that I did that was very
controversial people it it's very funny
the the pr Muslim Brotherhood thought
that this is a disrespect to the people
who died and on the other side the
people said that this is a disrespect to
the Army and when you manage to offend
everybody you know you're right yes and
in the people in the midd it's like oh
you weren't you weren't tough enough and
I was told I like why didn't you go
after the the the the the ceiling of
Freedom just went down and I was just
like it was very diff it is very
difficult to go
against an an authority that is very
that was very popular at the time and
especially a military Authority with all
all of experience oh yeah of weaponizing
these situations you had death threats
people would always choose most of the
time they always choose the military
form rather than the religious form
because they they kind of like uh at Le
they are not infringing on my personal
freedom not yet but you had threats on
your life didn't you oh all the time I
don't talk about that because like I
have been having death threats like did
never stopped since 2011 never stopped
have they continued since our last
interview oh yeah they never stopped
people threatening to kill you all the
time
why for what reason oh for just saying
something that they don't like oh
because you you are against Egypt you're
against Islam you're against our
president you're against God it it never
stops it never stops it doesn't doesn't
bother you I mean if you die you die you
know if you die you die I mean since
since when whatever like no bodyguards
deflected a bullet you know maybe the
guy who with Ronald Reagan but I I I I I
I think it's like whatever even like at
a certain point I actually had like
private security and then I told them I
can't I I cannot live like that if if
that's my destiny if I die I just
die you end up with your lawyer send you
got to get out of here you got to get
out of Egypt it's getting too dangerous
yeah something bad's going to happen
you're going to get arrested again and
probably sung in jail or you're going to
going to try and kill you and you flee
to Dubai and then you end up here in
America yes was that always the plan to
eventually come to America or was it
expediency because of what happened well
it's funny that you said that because I
visited the United States after the
first year of my show and uh um a doctor
that's there Gyptian doctor has been
there for for a while asisten Bim you
you are very visible in the media and I
think you can use that to apply for a
green card as a special talent and I did
and I said like I I I have like a huge
show is actually the criteria because I
have the same is uh alien of exceptional
ability is what they call you charmingly
yes we're very we exceptionally able
aliens we are but we are still aliens
yeah I know it always makes me laugh you
can come here but you are an alien alien
but you're exceptional and uh I um I
just applied for it and I got it I got
the time 100 that helped both from my uh
my application I said ah maybe I'm not
going to use it and then when that
happens oh that green card came handy so
a lot of people think that I'm here on
Asylum I'm not I just it was just a stri
good luck you now do stand up and you
done it for 5 years and fascinatingly
you do some of it for an Arab audience
have whole in Arabic and and an English
speaking version and they're probably
very different right different
sensibilities different humor different
crowds different expectation M yes well
well the Arab audience come to my show
they expect that it's going to be
another version of my show that I didn't
Egypt and I said no it's my personal
story and that when the Arabs come to my
English shows like they think this like
an English version of there of the show
was like no it's a different story even
then this weekend right before I met you
because of our interview I sold out
Arizona really yes and I and I and I
stood and the first thing I said like
who here came before over the peers
Morgan show I was like like I was like
boy you're going to be disappointed
because this is not about that but isn't
that amazing I mean that shows the power
of that interview resent even in in
Arizona here yeah because I don't want I
don't want to be I don't want to succeed
just because of a trending moment of
time it is the sh same show that I've
been working and perfecting and like any
standup comedian in the United States
your dream is what is to sell you
special to platforms like next HBO and
you want to get there because for me
that was like a like a re like a rebirth
because I thought like everything was
lost I came here I had
nothing first three four years it was
Terri the first two years I was doing
stand up oh I bombed hard I bombed hard
and I I went home crying I said like I'm
not going going to make it and then
suddenly I have already a tour I mean
even before our show I already had a set
tour and now I'm having like this
ability of like talking to people with
different languages talking to all these
different language the show that I did
in Arizona had an incredible mix of
Arabs and Americans and they came here
and they completely and there a lot of
them came they were Palestinians and
they came with like the Palestinian
flags and the cfea and they thought it's
like guys it's like the way laughter
being good at your job in in is in in
its way a a way of resistance because
when you laugh when you tell when you
show people that hey they have Arab
people here and they are by the Arabs
and Palestinians population Arizona one
of the most established population in
the United States Arabs nut s in general
they are like professionals doctors
Engineers professors even the Uber
drivers they are probably were like an
engineer or someone very established
there but he had to had like a step down
in order to come here and survive m i
mean we don't we we we hardly come find
like illegal aliens here from or people
like came here that were not qualified
so the and this is the problem of this
is why the reason people were very happy
of our interview because for for because
part of the
hate on both sides is that we see the
news from a different perspective and
people here see the news from another
perspective and everybody's like why are
those people reacting like this because
they don't see what the other person
sees and I hope in that interview that
we can bridge that Gap yes before before
we can I can I can I show okay so this
is a gift from me and my wife this is uh
olive oil from the West Bank ah whenever
you go to I go to Jordan a lot but my
wife also like ask for the oil from the
West Bank it's very
good it is the best oil ever and the
thing is olive trees they they know they
survive up to 600 years MH and they are
passed from one generation to the other
and uh it is like a family heritage and
the way that you do it so this is zat
zat is basically Thyme and you add to it
Sesame and a bunch of herbs and the way
that you eat that you take like a piece
of bread we don't have to do it now
maybe at the end of the interview the
end and you basically you soak it a
little bit in the oil and then you take
the outter and I I'll
demonstrate
here and then and then
here I love it well I love Arabic food
so the end of the interview you're
living with this o I will take that well
thank you and it's very kind of your
wife thank you thank you very much for
me well I'm done whoot it but it's
okay obviously you started the last
interview with I mean I would argue
savagely dark humor involving your wife
M how you been trying to kill her and
she was using your kids as human Shields
and stuff and I I'll be honest with you
I'm still trying to but I but you know
what when I failed you know what I did I
went out to the house and I just like
randomly slapped other neighbors you
know it's interesting by mistake now
this time I'm ready for you okay this
time I'm ready for the humor oh you're
ready okay but it's interesting because
last time I was very taken aback and I
remember thinking as you were doing this
at right off the top I remember feeling
very uncomfortable unusually
uncomfortable and thinking I didn't know
how to react to that I didn't know
whether I was supposed to laugh or be
silent or and I sort of ended up sort of
slightly grimacing half laugh and
listening and then I realized it was
very powerful what you were doing it was
satirical but it was savagely satirical
and extremely effective and that's why I
think the interview did so well but I'm
not going to pretend that I found it
easy to listen to it or to react to it
because I didn't you know why because
all I did was just take the talking
points that's been in the media not just
for after October 7th all through the
conflict it's always like we need to
kill it all right you need to kill five
no kill 10 you need to kill some no kill
all this is what satire does you takes
take reality flip on his head
exaggerated and then you can see how
sometimes very uncomfortable and even
sometimes stupid that sounds
because I was just reacting to whatever
the media is telling me it's like oh
yeah okay do it come there's no push
back so suddenly the person who's
proposing The Most Extreme Measures like
oh take it oh that's too much so that
that was like a very simple technique I
just talk took the talking point and
just exaggerated it was it was
devastatingly effective I um first
before we go any further how is your
wife's family because she is a
Palestinian yeah are they okay are no
they're good they're good they are safe
for now yeah um and as like that last
week there was no internet as you have
yes you know I saw you tweet at the IDF
it's like how can they know you know how
many views that tweets at nearly 40
million yeah me just saying how are they
going to see this message if you've cut
the internet off yeah I'm I'm wondering
if the idf's like why aren't the
Palestinians liking my tweet because
they don't see it right no but I thought
that was a perfectly yeah correct
assessment of it yeah um but the
reaction to that tweet I did was
enormous as everything is in this in
this thing and I had a lot of people say
finally p you get it right finally you
get it and and I wanted to say listen
I'm I'm trying to reach a place where I
get this but it's an incredibly
complicated issue for someone who is not
Arabic or Jewish to poke their head into
and I've had to cover it as a journalist
for a long long time think I said to you
before that I was elit of a Daily Mirror
in England when we opposed the Iraq War
for example so you know I have taken
stands on this thing on this one I find
and I'm going to be completely straight
with you I discussed this with Jordan
Peterson
um this week and he did a pretty incend
tweet in which he said give him hell
Netanyahu enough is enough and he was
actually very self-reflective about that
in the interview we did this week where
he later issued a 20 minute video
because he said sometimes a oneline
tweet can be unnecessarily inflammatory
to people much better to take time to
explain it here's here's where I've got
to with this conflict
now I viewed what happened on October
the 7th as is an absolutely appalling
atrocity a terror attack of unimaginable
horror and I absolutely think that
Israel has a right to defend itself from
the people who committed it Hass and
I've questioned for the last three four
weeks what is a proportionate response
and I have said repeatedly I don't know
the answer I want people who have a view
to have a view about that and I'll ask
you again about where you think we are
with this I also acknowledge that that
Hamas live among civilian population in
Gaza and therefore if you do what the
Israelis are currently doing which is a
ground offensive into Gaza a lot of
civilians are going to get killed and at
what point does that become
disproportionate or even
illegal and I don't know the answers to
those questions and I have a moral
quandry because my instinct is to say
that Israel has no choice but to respond
to what happened in a very forceful
manner I understand why they want to
eliminate Hamas Al together I understand
that if they feel they can then perhaps
we can move to a a two-state solution or
peace or whatever it may be alth I don't
think Netanyahu will ever be the person
to do that but the the moral question
for me is at what point does this become
disproportionate and when you see
thousands of children being killed in
Gaza it fills me with utter horror and
then people say well do you condemn it
and I find it very easy easy to condemn
Israel turning off the water Israel
turning off the power I think it's
ridiculous that Israel should have that
power over millions of people who are
not part of their country I think it's
terrible what's happening in the West
Bank with the settlers I think that the
stuff there is completely easy to
condemn but can I hand on heart condemn
Israel trying to destroy Hamas after
what they did on October the 7th that is
where I'm struggling to find myself
saying I condemn it because I believe
that they are right to try and Destroy
Hamas now what do you feel about my
moral quandry well there is there's a
lot of points very lot and I think this
is this was kind of like L the ground
rules for that uh interview there is a
whole thing about like is the right to
defend itself the condemnation first of
all let's start with condemnation yes
you want my opinion yes condemning Hamas
or condemning Israel yes completely
useless completely useless why
you I condemn Hamas you condemn Israel
interviews over what happened nothing it
is just
checkpoint like morality checkpoints but
I've interviewed a lot of pro
Palestinians for example some of whom
will immediately say I unreservedly
condemn the terror attacks of October
the 7th and then go on to criticize
Israel and I think that's a very well
it's a position I can completely respect
yeah but I find it much harder to
respect a pro Palestinian guest on my
show if they simply resolutely refuse to
say that they can condemn the terror
attacks I find that less worthy of
respect but you see this is the problem
with the news we go into the circular
motion of the same as one thing that I
have noticed not just on the coverage of
these events the the the events before
and before and before every time this
starts people say we don't know what's
happening it's a very complicated
situation what is happening now and for
me as a viewer if a conflict that's been
there for 75 years and the media with
all this technology has been covering it
and we hear the same exact words we
don't know what's happening it's
complicated it's a very complex that is
a failure of the media apparatus that is
the failure to themselves and for the
audience because why every time this
happens it seems like it is happening
from from from point zero and I think to
help understand that I will get to
October 7th I will get to the
condemnation I will get to the
selfdefense but I think maybe we can do
we have like all the time in the world
and we can discuss this could this
interview could be a bookmark Landmark
for maybe looking at that conflict in a
deeper way that nobody had gone there
before we have the views we have people
waiting you know as I said I'm the least
qualified to discuss that but it's an
opportunity to useen I'm not massively
well qualified myself yeah both of us
like I'm an Irish Catholic look at us
two privileged people one white one one
white white WABE discussing discussing
the the most complex conflict of of our
of our history but I want to start in a
totally different area I want to start
with anti-Semitism yes I think it's an
important issue yes I think there is a
rise of anti-em semitism in the world
and I think there is uh this is very
dangerous and I as a Muslim who has been
through events where the were terrorist
attacks somewhere and that reflects to
us on us I I completely completely feel
that uh since what happened I had text
message from the je friends are you okay
are you are wise family okay and I was
texting them are you okay are and I
think it is very
important to agree on the language
because the word
anti-semite has been used and abused and
most most most of the time not on for
the you know for the good in um interest
of the Jewish people because the first
two days of the coverage I watched the
news and I and there was a lot of um
protest that was led by Jewish voice for
peace and they were read by people who
opposed the Israeli attack on the
civilians and I remember quite well many
of the Republican representatives in
Congress came out and they were called
calling these the global in the global
Jihad I love it when they say Jihad they
sound like a horse Jihad it's very funny
and or they they say like these are and
I quote Iranian backed jihadists and I
said wait a minute but most of those
people are Jewish those people who took
over the capital the same people who
took over Central Station in New York
which is known as the biggest Civil
Disobedience event in America in the
last two decades they were all Jewish
and then I find Nikki haly saying
anti-zionism equals
anti-Semitism and then I remember it's
like oh Jewish people in America are
saddled by the fact that they are not
citizens of America or citizens of the
world but they are citizens of Israel
and they have to back Israel in whatever
they do and these are not my words these
are the words of John Stewart he went
out and he said he said like and he said
it's is very very important to divide
these two and what is very very
interesting would you compare that on
that specific point to the way that
people try and say all Palestinians are
responsible and accountable for what
Hamas do yes yeah in other words I think
you can be very critical of Israeli
government and their policies and
Benjamin Netanyahu and the politicians
but that doesn't mean that you have to
take that criticism to innocent Israelis
who may have exactly the same criticism
themselves and this is why it is very
important to have these kind of
discussions because it the fun is not
the the funniest the saddest thing that
I saw is the people that were in so much
support of Israel are anti-semite
themselves MTG MTG MTG uh merie Taylor
green you know she said like oh those
are I send my AIDS and they took
pictures of the protesters basically
she's surveilling protesters
and M Taylor green is very known for a
very famous Post in 2018 where she
blamed the californ wild fires on a
Jewish space laser gun do you remember
that do you remember that I say like oh
they were burn because Jewish investors
Rothchild and fin anything was that ends
with Stein because that's of course
sounds of Jewish they put a satellite
and shooting laser beams
to and and and not just her you have
Steve
scolis thank you so much he is the now
the the speaker of the house and he has
been invited before in a in a for an
organization that was funded by David
Duke the founder of the KKK you have
Kevin McCarthy who is the former
minority speaker leader of of Republican
party in the house and he accused Jewish
billionaires of rigging the midterm so
how come those people are accusing us of
anti-semite so here's the thing so go
let's go to the equation that Niki Haley
put on Twitter anti-zionism equals
anti-semitism no it is true people who
hate Jews they're also anti Zionist it
is true and you could be someone who
hate Zionist who don't like Zionist and
you are Semite you could even be Jewish
and guess what you could be a Zionist
like those
people uh supporting Israel and at the
same time you hate the Jews because the
chant Jews will not replace us these
echoed in Charlottesville it did not
echo in Gaza I mean in Gaza they say War
stuff in in between the bombing under
downtime but and these are are the same
people who are seen with Nick
Fuentes with
uh with Steven benon and you know what's
most interesting for dinner Mar and all
of those people are buddies with
Benjamin Netanyahu so how does this work
how does this work and you know the
people who speak against this like John
Stewart Like Bernie Sanders like uh
Naomi Klein what do they call these
people what do they call them
self-hating Jews and you know what else
now they call them they call them capus
capus you know what's capus capus
basically these were the Jewish inmate
in aitz that were forced by the Nazis to
stand as guards on their own inmates you
see how degrading this is and this is
the way to shut down conversation
anti-semite islamophobe you hate America
you hate the military you hate Egypt war
on Christmas this is how you sh an
environment that does not allow
disagreement is not an environment made
for it's an environment made for control
let me ask you this on say temp student
protests in America universities I have
no problem instinctively with students
protesting it's actually part of the DNA
of being a student right but I do have a
problem with two things one the protest
that happened almost immediately after
October the 7th within hours which were
clearly deeply deliberately inflammatory
and hurtful to Jewish
people secondly I have a real problem
with the students who were beaming
direct Pro Hamas slogans onto buildings
on campuses in America you know I'm all
for free speech and I really am the
whole show is predicated from that but
not to the point where you see Jewish
students barricaded into libraries
because a mob is descending on them
there is a distinction to me between
people who are obviously overtly I mean
there was a professor at Cornell
University who was literally seen in
public shouting how exhilarated he felt
by the attacks of October the 7th he
still hasn't been fired that guy I think
that crosses a line to you yeah I do not
like this way I mean I can understand
why but I don't condone it I would never
because you have to understand these
people again I'm not supporting the I
just want to make sure about two things
the reason that I started with
anti-Semitism because I wanted to make
sure to clear any confusion that when I
speak about Israel I'm speaking about
Israel yes when I speak about Jewish
people I'm speak about Jewish people yes
when I speak of my it's very because I
think it was very powerful that you did
that I that's the first thing you did
because I think it's really important
yeah but at the same time when I tell
you why does that happen it doesn't mean
that I condone it there's a difference
between explanation and
justification those people who are
exhilarated the way that they this is
the the same uh reason why people were
so happy about the
interview what do they see they see
Israel as a criminal State who is
killing their people and in the same
time they are supported by the
International Community
America they have no guns they have no
superpower backing them all they have is
just feeling of Happiness like yes our
enemies that we cannot touch them has
been hurt all they can think about that
these are their enemies that have been
hurt right I'm not condoning this but
again like when people were uh
celebrating terrorist attacks you know
against Western uh Western targets of
course I don't condone that but why
because those people has been from from
a very young age what have seen they're
not being heard by the media the The
Plight and the suffering of their
brothers in is in in Palestine in the
Arab world are not being heard people in
Iraq you know like when when America and
Britain invaded Iraq right what what the
Arabs saw it's like two superpowers are
coming in on on just regular people so
whenever there was like a bomb or like
an attack on American troops people
would celebrate yeah there are enemies
emotions are very inflammatory and it is
not right but those people have nothing
else all they just like shout all they
say is like to to to rejoice it is not
right again I'm explaining why is this
happening because it's like yeah if I
cannot get you I'm just going to scratch
your eyes I'm going to scratch your eyes
because because you've been beating me
all the time and you have the whole
International Community backing you up
and all I can do is Scream is it right
no but it is understandable again not
the right thing but I it's not like
understandable it's like oh I no but
again it is an explanation now hate and
again this is another way why this has
been magnified in the media so much what
does the Western audience see they see
people rejoicing for the death of
innocent civilians in
Israel this is what have the Arabs seen
for years in in on the Arab board for
example if you look up sidro
Cinema this is in 2014 when when Israel
was bombing Gaza as usual and the
Israelis in the sidro uh uh the Kuts or
the the settlement they were see they
went on a hill and they had popcorn and
they had drinks and they were like
watching the show and they were cheering
with every rocket coming down this is
what we see Western people didn't see
that well somebody found a tweet
actually of mine from
2014 in which I said at what point does
what Israel is currently doing to the
Palestinian people will become terrorism
and because I've always said you know
I've spoken about this a lot over the
years and I've always tried to be
extremely fair-minded albeit nobody
really wants you to be fair-minded they
want you to take a side but that was
clear that my thinking back then was
that they were absolutely overstepping
absolutely absolutely but I'm again to
the point of rejoicing no I know what
you mean but like if you for example
Google Google the wedding of hate this
is like an a Jewish wedding in Israel
where they were celebrating the arson
and the of Palestinian to be clear I've
seen lots of vide but I'm not talking to
you pierce I'm I'm talking to the
Western audience because because I want
to see like I want to say like this is
what they see I mean for example there
is a very famous video for Sam Abu Z who
is like a young kid that he was shot
Point Black by an Israeli soldier and he
would not allowed to have any medical
attention and as his dead body was being
put into the ab ambulance the Jewish
settlers were cheering so for an Arab
audience this is what we see every day
so when they see oh we heard them back
we heard their people like they heard
back it is not right but this is what
hates does it escalates it feeds each
other radicalism feeds it it is terrible
and it is a it is just like a vicious
circle so I would like to do something
that is very interesting toight I want
when I invited John Stewart to my show
as much of like a reception that you if
you see the YouTube people just like we
had to cut the 5 minute standing ovation
for broadcast people was on their feet
for 5 minutes they could not believe it
I remember John telling me I could never
imagined that a Jewish guy from New
Jersey would have that kind of reception
in K and yet on the internet people who
would what you brought a Jew on your
show why you are with a Jew yes hate is
there yes so and and the thing is like
why we do not see each other people in
the Middle East people in the west that
we do not put ourselves in each other
shoes and I want to do something very
interesting today I want to give I I'm
I'm I'm I like telling stories and I'm
going to tell you a very nice story and
this is the story surprise surprise of
the suffering and the plight of the
Jewish people and I want to say that
because it is very inter when you see
the
trauma and the suffering that the people
on the other side went through you might
understand why why they coming so so
this this
is see this mhm this is a map of all of
the history of the expulsion of the Jews
in Europe they' have been like I have
not never seen a minority being kicked
around this much right and of course
this comes back to the you know the
whole idea about the original sin that
you have uh betrayed the Jesus Christ
the the the the the the blood of Jesus
is on your head and then comes the 11th
century at that time Jewish people were
not allowed to own land they were just
peasants even some of the professions
were not even allowed to participate in
but they were allowed to do one thing
usually money lending because it was
prohibited by the Catholic Church to
engage into that so what happens when
you work in money you get richer right
and those Jews left in ghettos now
ghettos was not just like isolated
neighborhoods in cities sometimes
ghettos were outside the cities this is
like how is isolated their were and in
those GTO they have to pay gold to the
mayor or the governor or the prince or
the noble so they would see you're
getting richer I need more taxes so they
pay tax what happens when you have a
business and they increase your rent you
increase your service increase the taxes
increase so what happened what the
Christians started to default and
suddenly the image of the greedy Jew was
created Merchant of Venice if it
will feed nothing else it will feed my
venge you know like never did I see
known a creature like you know like like
uh I can't remember that never I saw
that a creature that looked like a man
so keen and greedy confound so confound
of a man you know English I messed it up
anyways but this is this is was the
image greedy Jew the greed je this was
created because of their conditions and
it came became more for in
1095 when Pope Urban II called for the
First Crusade to go and and and and save
the birth the birth of Jesus from the
unbelievers Muslim and you know this
crusade did not kill a single Muslim you
know how many people they killed 2,000
Jews because it's like wait the
nonbelievers are all over there why so
they went to the it's called The
Crusades of the Rin land they went to
the Jewish Community because hey we own
the money so let's kill them better than
paying them and then came the plague and
then all of the things like oh they're
killing babies babies who would that do
that to a baby you know and they accused
them of of poisoning the well this was
the kind of Oppression that the Jewish
people went through fast forward 19th
century there was like the Eastern Jew
in Ukraine and and Russia and there was
the Western Jews in
Europe those people in the East the
Eastern Jews had to immigrate because
they were PMs and they were like you
know kicked out and at a certain point
the people in the west especially in
England it's like H there are too many
Jews we need a solution a solution for
what for the Jewish problem so it's like
we need to get rid of them and you know
what Palestine was not even on the in
the a list Palestine was in the b list
because England proposed 6,000 square
miles in Uganda for the Jews
1903 and the reason why Palestine was
not on the list that it was objected by
a lot of rabbis that said like it's a
Promised Land but only when the Messiah
comes but there were other options
Argentina South Africa Uganda Madagascar
and eventually they said all right let's
do Palestine so they went to Palestine
1914 there was 700,000 people living in
Palestine 3% were Jewish 1917 Bel for
declaration Arthur Bel for he called the
Jewish people in England that they are
alien and hostile race and the thing is
the only Jewish member of the parliament
of the English Parliament Lord monu he
objects like these are British citizens
they we should not kick them out so they
pushed them they pushed them but it was
not going fast enough came the Nazis and
then it was not about the solution
anymore it was the end losing the Final
Solution by Hitler because he needed an
answer for the Jewish question the
you and then the as you see the
Holocaust happened the most orchestrated
industrialized horrible genocide in our
modern time 6 million Jews died so it
accelerated and they went first of all
they left Eastern Europe and they went
to West Europe and went to America and
they were turned down and were pushed
towards Palestine so by 1948 right
before the Declaration of the state of
Israel there were 2 million people
living there only 30% of them was Jews
so the whole idea of like a land without
a people to a people without a land was
a marketing thing they were already
Palestinians so suddenly from our
perspective the Jewish problem is not a
Jewish problem is not a middle eastern
problem is not an Arab problem it is a
European problem it was pushed on us
together with the guilt because now we
are the anti-semite we now we are the
Jewish ha
and not just that they took land so
people look at this like why are we even
we we had a lot of refugees coming in
and during that there was a lot of as
you know zist militia the Aragon the
hagana all of these people were killing
palestin the the famous Massacre of Dar
scene you're talking about the
atrocities of October 7 is horrible but
in the Arab mind there is there scene
where there is an incredible movie
called tour t a t t a n t o r a where
they the the Israeli members of those uh
militias they talk about the atrocities
that they did including opening up the
pregnant woman bellies and having bets
if the boy inside is a boy or a girl it
is one of the most horrific and they
talk about it some talk about with
regret and some talk about with pleasure
we did that right so you have
even King David I think your prime
minister Mr sunak was there and I as I
if I was British I would question this
because as you know King David was
bombed by the Aragon militias 91 British
solders died I don't know as a if I was
British how come my prime minister would
have the nerve to stay in that hotel I
mean you know the ghost of the 91
British soldiers that must be haunting
for them you see so when you see all of
that and you see that suddenly overnight
1948 there were one 1.5 million
Palestinians seven half of them three4
of them were overnight pushed into
refugees and this why it's called the
NBA the catastrophe so now we have all
of this building up into the minds and
that and S suddenly this was like a
conflict a hate a problem that we didn't
have to do anything with this was
basically pushed on us by the Europeans
you see see this is why it is important
to say that and I'm not saying that just
like oh let's Wipe Out the state of
Israel let's like push them in the sea
no but it's important when you talk
about about the conflict that you talk
about the root causes right no there
were there was like a vibrant
Palestinian culture happening over there
and right now they are erasing this
culture suddenly I'm seeing of like
Israeli fetes Israeli homus oh that's an
insult Israeli homus come on I mean take
the land but leave the homeless man I
mean come on I mean that's that's not
fair you are someone who's always spoken
against cultur cancelled culture right
now a whole culture is canceled let let
me ask you this Jonathan fredland is a
top Jewish journalist for the Guardian
newspaper he wrote a very interesting
column last week in which he
said at the root of all this you could
argue you have two sets of people with
just
calls and they believe passionately in
their Just
Cause And he was sort of advising people
not to take sides unless you really
understand the history do you would you
agree with that would you agree that
both sides have legitimate just cause
not with the methodology that's taken
place and you've given an extremely
detailed analysis of the buildup to what
happened in 48 to me it's pretty clear
700 800,000 Palestinians were displaced
from their and it should never have
happened and that has been absolutely I
think the root cause for so much
resentment but can you at the heart of
this debate agree with Jonathan that you
could argue there's just cause on both
sides there's a there is a cause on both
sides but I I I'm I'm working on a tight
robe here because I'm not a Palestinian
yeah uh but from the Palestinian point
of view there's a lot of people I mean
there are 2.2 million people living in
Gaza there are 3.5 million people living
in the West Bank there is 350,000 people
lifting in eism and there's like six or
seven million people living outside
those people the Palestinian that were
pushed out they do not have the right to
go back right now if you meet
Palestinians you'll see them wearing a
necklace with a key that key is their
house that do kicked out from in in yafa
and he you know like my my my wife's
family comes from ramla which is 50 mi
from Gaza and and and according to the
law those people have absolutely no
right to go back even you if you are a
Palestinian with an American passport
they give you hell in order to go in and
yet a Jewish person born anywhere in the
world born in Poland born in near
Ukraine no question ask he can jump on a
plane land in Israel and get the the the
the Israeli Citizen and take a house
that most probably belonged to a
Palestinian so it is not just like a it
is an ongoing Injustice that has been
happening now I mean where would you
criticize if you're being
fair-minded where would you criticize
from 48 onwards the behavior of the Arab
side well put yourself in the Arab side
at 1948 you constituted 70% of the
population Sou the UN is giving you 48%
of the
land right not just that I mean the Arab
regimes because they did terribly and
see this is the thing Arab nationalism
at the height of these people feed on
each other you know because it's very
very important to have a problem oh it's
Israel and then and for isra oh it's the
Palestinian it's a very good distraction
I mean sometimes I feel that like the
Palestinian cause is very useful for
both sides to stay there as attention
because it's all a way to reflect but uh
and this is a very important question
because the in the mind of the western
audience they always thought of the
Palestinian resistance or the
Palestinian side as like Islamic as
militant no as a matter of fact some of
the early suicide bombers were female
Christian Palestinians because they like
the r you know they were fighting for a
land the whole idea of islamization of
the whole cause came very later as a m
fact you will find this very interesting
because when I saw this I did not
believe it this you know the fat
movement which is the PLO the fat this
was their uh
slogan can you see you see there's a
crescent a cross and a minora and they
say unitary Democratic non sectarian so
basically in the 1960 fat were basically
marijuana smoking Tre Huger hippies and
yet that didn't work right and the thing
is is I always hear that like Arabs were
giving two four so many chances for
peace that is not true as a matter of
fact all along history Israel didn't
give an inch of land by peace 1974 73
War they gave back Sinai because Egypt
like initiated the war 2006 they went
out of uh south of Lebanon because of
the resistance they have even the
disengagement of of Gaza they didn't do
it out of the goodness of their heart
because they had too much casualties and
even even even the oso Accords the peace
treaty the one that Isaac Rabin and got
the Nobel Prize they did it because of
the in so what is the message that
Israel is giving to the Arabs I will
never give you anything with peaceful
resolution you will always have to fight
for it do you not think that for example
I mean Bill Clinton feels this very
strongly that there was a great deal to
be done and Arafat just in the end
having indicated the whole time that if
we got to this place there would be a
deal just walked away so that was the
closest that everybody came and but
actually I mean could Clinton have done
any more than he tried to do then I am
not again that's why it's very important
to have people who are much more
qualified than me to talk about this but
two things I can say about that number
one
uh the the whole thing about the Osa
Accord there was a video for Netanyahu
who was talking to the S offer 01 and he
was bragging about sabotaging the he was
talking to like I sabotage it like there
was going to be no peace yeah you seen
that right and in that video if you
remember when when he was saying like
you have to hit them hard 2001 no Hamas
at the time we have they were talking
about the Palestinian Authority we have
to hit them we have to kill them we have
to make them feel the pain and then one
of the says like like BB but wouldn't
America kind of J like so what the
American public is easily manipulated
80% are with us it is
and as a new American where I can have
the um privilege of being
retrospectively angry as I like this guy
is mocking the government who is and the
people who have been with him all the
time it's like oh they can be easily
manipulated they can do and even by the
way even Isaac Robin Isaac Robin the the
one who actually did the Peace AR he was
known famously said the way to actually
beat those children is to break their
bones with the broken bones policy they
were like get those kids and break their
bombs on the FV so this has the whole
idea about like Israel wanted peace and
Arabs only wanted to fight is a very
very bad think as as it's gone on the
will the genuine will on both sides for
peace has not existed no I think it's
been a deceit to the world I'm and and
to the relative groups of people on both
sides the official and actually a
betrayal of the official stand of the
Palestinian Authority and again I cannot
speak it is very difficult to do this
the official send of the pales authority
is that we are just happy with 22% of
the land just give us like the yes there
are people that this but the thing is
you cannot just say okay let's talk
about peace and then you take away my
land let's talk about peace and there's
there's a kind of like passive
aggressiveness happening oh let's talk
about but I'm going to build settlements
I'm going to suffocate your cities and
your Villages see I think that has been
incredibly inflammatory yes worsening
the situation I think putting back the
chance of peace I mean Netanyahu
interviewed Netanyahu earlier this year
in the middle of the big social protests
in his own country and I couldn't
understand what he thought he was doing
except that it seemed to me political
expediency that he had to to get power
uh you know again he had put a bunch of
right-wing Headbangers into his cabinet
who have incredibly bad records speak in
an incredibly incend way about uh
Palestinians for example and that he did
this for power and then he launched a
because they were pushing him to do it a
ridiculous assault on the Integrity of
the Supreme Court indep Supreme Court
and and many Israelis rose up so
Netanyahu is has become to me a big
problem right and and the people that
all the polling shows that Israeli
people are very unhappy with Netanyahu I
don't think he's ever going to actually
want to forge peace and in fact I think
he was instrumental with Hamas in
wanting to keep them in power because he
felt that that would create the split
with the Palestinian with two political
groups and that would be good for Israel
and it was leaked in a leak Hood uh
conference in 2019 that he was bragging
about giving Hamas money because this is
a way that we can keep Palestinian
divided and yet so we we and we'll never
have on so this is a guy who was look we
can agree about Netanyahu I think no but
not just Netanyahu there there's a and
would say most of his cabinet there's a
book called the fear of Peace it's
called by mushe
Zimmerman and he's an Israeli historian
and he said like the average Israeli
citizen does not have a vision of Peace
because for 70 years this is a country
that has been the military war has been
going on for they have been expanding
because of war the milit is taking over
so the whole idea of peace is not even
there it's not just Netanyahu like like
you have I remember you have interviewed
Neftali Benet yes and I think you
tweeted that like that was like a very
um kind of reasonable take yeah is it
reasonable yeah yeah but like I this ne
ne in that he went after Queen R and he
call a shame on Queen R I didn't say
reasonable I just said this I did a a
fire Emoji yeah I just said that what he
was saying yeah I mean I was going to
ask you about Queen Ryan and let's ask
about since you've raised it because
Queen Ria accused the west of a glaring
double standard she said this is the
first time in modern history there's
such human suffering and the world is
not even calling for ceasefire so the
silence is deafening and to many in our
region it makes the Western World
complicit uh now other people said well
okay if you feel that
strongly why aren't you taking in any
Palestinians why is Egypt not taking
Palestinians why does the Arab world
want to constantly attack Israel without
actually offering any place to go for
the Palestinians and what do you say
that that is exactly what Israel wants
and that is exactly what might actually
start third War I this is the war
solution these are Palestinian these are
their lands and then sudden take them
why so they being basically kicked
around from their homes and now another
country should take them you see what
will happen imagine this now and because
Israel official has been talking openly
about this it's like why don't they just
go in sin why they go you know what
would happen those people going to be
pushed in Sinai and with any population
2 million people that are living in
refugee camp what do you think will
happen
unrest chaos and then after a few years
the Western media will come with their
cameras like oh look at those Arabs oh
they're killing each other oh Israel is
good that they got rid of them and then
they will go to the West Bank and so
those 3.5 million people pushing into
Jordan This the whole idea why does
Jordan take them why does Egypt take
them the same question you Europe has 44
countries why don't they take
Israel America has 50 states why why
don't they give them Florida I mean they
we seem to complain about Florida the
whole time why don't they just like give
Israel the whole idea was like oh you're
Arabs you're all the same no no no
because what will happen that so Israel
will move into Jordan it's like oh Saudi
why don't you take the
Jordanian this is not a solution this is
not a solution I I hear you I'm not
taking a position out the way let me ask
you direct I want to say something about
what queen rer said okay the whole idea
about like the West yeah I think that in
three weeks Israel morally corrupted the
West like no other I think the West will
have a lot of time to recover because
for years the West has been telling us
oh look we are liberal we're all about
human rights all are equal adopt our
values and then suddenly but you you
don't want to even to seee you don't
want to even tell Israel to stop and
suddenly we woke up and we found
McDonald's are giving free meals to the
Israeli because like nothing will make
you feel better after killing a bunch of
Palestinian kids than a Happy Meal so
let me ask you they have a toy so this
brings me to Hamas okay so what Israel
will say because they say it to me every
time they come on the program whoever
from meu Barack to Natalia Bennett
whoever it may be they say look we
suffered such a catastrophic terror
attack on October the 7th that we have
decided we are going to get rid of Hamas
there are 40,000 or so Hamas terrorists
in their eyes who need to be got rid of
and I do believe they're terrorists only
terrorist can commit the kind of Act of
terrorism we saw so can we on that point
can we agree on that do you believe
Hamas is a terror group it is what it is
classified by America I I'm not a big
fan of Hamas and they are militant group
they does like stuff like are they
terrorist do you think yeah cool okay
okay so we agree on this so you have
40,000 of them living in Gaza amongst
the civilian population if Israel has
decided to eliminate a terror group
Hamas as the world did with Isis for
example and I think there are a lot of
parallels given the way they behave on
October the 7th to Isis how do you do it
how do you do it if you don't do it the
way Israel is currently trying to do it
exactly not the way that Israel does it
because if you have the one of the most
advanced
military powers in the world and it
takes you 3 weeks 9,000 Palestinian
civilian death 21,000 injured as we
talking right now Israel just bombed
Galia which is a known refugee camp this
it is a very this is a this is not
self-defense you know like one of the
most questions like does Israel have the
right to defend itself this is a no
value question this is a no value
question well I would ask a different
point I would say not only do they have
a right to defend themselves which every
country would after a terror attack
right but they actually have a duty and
responsibility to their
population to try and stop that
happening again to them they've been
doing and I do I do understand and I
agree with that yeah but but here's the
thing if it takes you all of that time
all of these civilians to take out a few
hundred gorilla Fighters we don't know
how many of the people di we don't know
it does matter but B you don't know and
I don't know we don't know but like we
don't even know if the casualty numbers
are correct because they're all coming
from Hass and wealth and we should
believe Israel no no not necessarily no
no I I don't believe either side but but
but here's my problem with this here's
my point I don't think we should assume
that we know these statistics are
correct I don't think we should assume
we know exactly how many children have
been killed we do know a lot have been
killed so the moral argument Remains the
Same but we don't know how many Hamas
terrorists have been killed in the last
three weeks we just don't know do we so
basically we're we're dealing with a
very incompetent military force that has
been sucking America dry for years and
then they cannot do the job but how else
do they get rid of herass not like that
how do they do it I don't know but not
like that because they've been trying
they have first of all I'm not a
military expert second of all second of
all they've been trying the same thing
for years they go in
they this is not an eye for an eye
anymore this is an eye a limp a life a
house a neighborhood a whole population
for an eye they don't say I mean your
your friend Ben shapira that you
particularly despise oh I love Ben
shapir he's very smart yeah but you
you've been very critical of him and
that's fair enough and I'm sure he would
be of you but when I asked him about
proportion he said there is I don't care
about a proportionate response so let's
K civilians as Hamas did this so we are
going to get rid of Hamas it's it's in
his eyes it wasn't I for an i Toth for a
tooth it was this group of terrorists
did this and we are now going to rid the
world of these terrorists and this is
very important to look at things in
context when you see how Israelis Talk
inside their Community there was a very
famous post by or ual he is the uh
Speech writer of Nan he said what is so
horrific about understanding that the
whole Palestinians people are our
enemies all of them are enemy compa we
should call them kill their mother
destroy their homes the homes that they
raise those snakes so no snakes would be
raised in this house anymore and this
was reposted by Al Chet which is the
Minister of wait for it
justice those this it's not about Hamas
anymore it is not about H they can tell
you it's about Hamas but it's not about
it is basically it has they have said it
many times Pierce this is a way to kind
of push them in into Sinai this is not
about eradicating Hamas this ship has
sailed I am sorry but like I anybody who
still believe that this is about Hamas
is stupid because they I don't agree
with that really no because I think but
why so why are why there I tell you I
don't agree there like 100 people any
country any country that suffered the
kind of terror attack that Israel
suffered with the kind of death toll
that occurred that day 1500 plus people
grandmothers kids young women being
raped kidnapped beheaded it's been
reported and so on well you can raise an
eyebrow I mean they found they found a
young woman's skull
Som been about the babies that were
beheaded well there was a report and you
and I have this discussion on there you
falsely quoted me and I wanted to
clarify that with you in person you
thought I'd said that 40 babies have
been beheaded you say I never said that
did you say I said it's been reported
that 40 babies were killed some of whom
had been beheaded that's what I said
yeah totally totally different is a very
different well it is different yes you
accept it um English is a second
language so things they different things
of course yes between saying 40 babies
have been beheaded and 40 babies have
been reported to been killed including
are those beheaded Beed well apparently
journalists have being shown utterly
horrific okay this is this comes to a
very important question about
credibility again I'm not condoning what
happen OCT but in I'm not a journalist
but as a journalist wouldn't you take
anything that an authority would say
with a grain of thought yes especially
if this Authority have a
long history of lying and I'm just going
to give a few example 1996 they bombed
Kan it's a refugee camp they killed 106
people and despite that they knew it's a
refuge Camp they said oh maybe it's a
one time off 2006 they W con again 2014
they killed two teenagers at checkpoint
they denied as usual but CNN was there
so they said we have to say it 2018 they
killed a medic a Palestinian medic and
they doctored they fabricated a video
showing that it's someone else that he
was a human shield and then can I just
like finish I want respond and and then
2010 they killed Ahmed orat denied it
then said it's okay it's us 20121 they
bomb the media office in it's not us but
no I'm sorry and then 11th May 2022
Shireen reporter your colleague she's
Palestinian American citizen she was
shot in the head and they provide Ed
forensic evidence and even a doctor
video that it was not them it was
Islamic Jihad how can I expect to
believe this regime especially if the
president of Israel comes down with this
ridiculous ridiculous thing have you
seen in there there he said okay this
was reported by Sky News and it was the
funniest thing I've SE so my this was a
call and po moment but like the cheap
Edition Mr uh herok said like Isaac hok
it's like we have
found evidence on one of the uh um
terrorist a manual to create chemical
bombs and then he showed this and he
showed and this is I just want to say
why would a foot shoulder go in into
enemy with like a manual to chemical
bombing it's like is that Bob bring your
own beer bomb it's crazy and and what
what you like have like local
ingredients to make and then this is
like this is a ual of of course conven
and let me read it to you in Arabic
because this is
funny which basically
say this is basically like a catalog for
self-improvement for
M I didn't know that they have life
coaches so this and you know what SK new
said like we cannot confirm or any of
this but we will show it
anyways this is like this government so
let me respond I do think the Israeli
government has lied all the time right I
do think they've lied I'm not going to
dispute that I do think they've been
caught lying I do think they said things
that turned out not to be true I also
think that two weeks ago a hospital was
bombed yes and it was immedi well I'm
going to tell you what I think Hamas
immediately tell the world it was an
Israeli air strike and that 500 people
were killed and that the hospital had
been destroyed and then as the next
couple of days go by the hospital is
relatively undamaged car park was
obliterated many fewer people than 500
were killed how many people died we
don't know because actually we're
relying on the Palestinian health
authority which is Hamas in Gaza for the
figures so we don't know the number but
a lot fewer people died it would appear
than the 500 we don't know 50 either way
it's appalling but it may not have been
anywhere near as appalling as was first
said by Hamas but here's the point most
independent studies of what happened
have concluded that it was almost
certainly a militant struck terror group
inside Gaza and they fired a rocket
which landed in the hospital car park in
other words it wasn't an Israeli air
strike so I have an issue with that
because for three days before the attack
the priest and the Patrick of the
hospital because it called the the
Baptist Hospital said that they have
received warning multip warning from
Israel that they're going to hit the
hospital and then at the time of the hit
of the hospital one of the top AIDS of
Netanyahu he tweeted about like we hit
the hospital and then he deleted and
then basically like Israel Gaz lighted
the
world why I said most independ no that's
not true New York Times actually like
just published something to prove that
it was shot from Israel and I think it's
no they didn't okay numbers they numbers
B that's not true okay the New York
Times has not reported that it was
Israel no they said the they haven't
okay that's not true over 10 years
Hamas launched 35,000 Rockets into
Israel how many failed they killed 69
people and uh 25% military only part of
them were civilians so over 10 years of
35,000 Rockets they killed 69 people but
in one strike you want to tell me that
these glorified
firecrackers caused that kind of damage
uh yes it looks like they did yeah okay
yeah and actually it wasn't the damage
that was reported by Hamas who wanted
people to believe it was Israeli air
strike so my point would be I'm happy to
concede that Israel government has lied
about stuff over the years but I'm
absolutely certain as well that Hamas
lie all the time why are holding
including I believe from all I've read I
believe they lied about the hospital why
are we holding the militant terrorist
group to the same standards as the best
and
because they to be they happened to be
the ruling party in Gaza so they're not
just a terror group they are a political
group as well political party okay well
they are so the question again comes
this and so far you've ducked it so I
want to ask you one more
time we can both agree that the scenes
in Gaza right now are horrific because I
do feel that but I don't know how else
Israel can eradicate Hamas than the way
that they're currently trying to do do
it do you have an alternative for them
well again we are locked in the same
thing what can we do now but we don't
look at what was happening over that you
the best recruiter for Hamas is
Israel I mean you have talked a lot
about the horrible condition in Gaza I
mean let's imagine like a little boy
called Ramy he lives in Gaza you know he
have a horrible life but like you know
it's like it's not that bad I know he
has a cousin in the West Bank he's
living a good life he wake up in the
morning and he found out that he was
kidnapped by three settlers he was
burned alive by kerosene and he was
forced to drink the kerosene his name
was Muhammad Abu that settlers did that
to him in 2016 said all right you know
what I'm just going to leave is I'm
going to find a way to go to Europe his
aunt is an a published author and she
won a prize in the Frankfurt book fair
his name is AD and now she was cancelled
because of what's happening just because
of her Palestinian his other aunt in
America his
namei she is a speech therapist and I
this is close to my heart because of my
son and she was uh fired because she did
not want to sign the for government cont
said that you cannot join BDS which I
don't understand why do people choosing
to protest peacefully by not buying
goods from a certain country why would
the United States make that its own
issue so and this guy this this Ramy is
being approached by like join ham join
us let's go kill is no no no no I don't
want to kill I just I'm going to live in
it's a life but 97% of water is not good
for human consumtion half of the
population are anemic even the is not
being treated and it goes into the
shores of Israel it's like oh that was
it's horrible so and then he and he
wakes up in the morning he doesn't think
about killing Jews the first thing in
the morning he thinks about being there
at 5:00 at the first 50 people in the
line for bread because if he doesn't he
will miss the food for his family and he
goes back and he finds a message saying
that we are going to bomb your house he
comes back he loses his old family now
tell me what is the proportionate
response for that I don't know I don't
know you cannot create terrorism and
then you I don't know you have they have
created this would I don't I don't know
is the answer but bam let me ask you
this Hamas will have known when they
perpetrated what they did in October the
7th what the scale of response was
likely to be how does that help the
Palestinian people they are supposed to
serve I don't know the the the wheels
are already set in motion but it doesn't
does it I do not you know is thing I
feel sometimes that Hamas is with us in
the room that we are bringing Hamas who
has the power in this equation who has
the fourth largest and strongest
military power the whole idea about
Israel it's like oh my God we are they
the Arabs are going to destroy us look
at the map Hamas hang on let me hang on
hamas's stated goal is the eradication
of Israel and the Jewish people yes they
make no pretense about it they've made
no attempt unlike the Nazis who try to
cover up their crimes they made no
attempt to try and deny what they they
brazenly boasted about it they are proud
of what they did right and they will
have known again that the scale of what
they did in October the 7th would have
prompted this kind of response which
would have led to thousands of innocent
Palestinians getting killed and my
question for you I wish the 7th of
October never happened every time every
you say Hamas is everywhere well yeah
actually all roads all roads on this
particular part of the crisis and I
accept it's been going on for 75 years
of conflict but all roads in this crisis
lead to Hamas and what they did and and
not necessarily because because all
roads goes to the condition that created
Hamas if the if the Jewish people were
expelled from Europe and went to
Argentina or South Africa and Uganda and
went in and took the land you would have
Hamas in all you and I can agree that
the conditions Palestinian people have
had to endure in Gaza for a very long
time completely unacceptable I think
it's completely unacceptable that Israel
has wielded such control over the people
of Gaza working out who can come in and
who can go out turning on and off Water
and Power on a whim turning off the
internet on and off at a whim all that
kind of stuff I can completely agree
with but given that I think we agree
Hamas are a terror group let's say let
me finish my question given that we
agree that Hamas is a teror organization
who have a publicly stated position of
annihilating not just Israel but Jewish
people and as we saw on October the 7th
they mean it if you are Israel what do
you do to get rid of those people who
have shown the world that's exactly what
they will actually do if they get the
chance you know what I to
do I would give the Palestinians what
they
deserve terrorism is a virus yes it's a
virus I agree if a patient with a flu
came to you and you're a doctor how can
you treat that
patient how do you treat as a doctor how
do you do well you're the doctor you
give them nutrition yeah fluids yeah and
rest so the immunity of the body gets
rid of the virus on its
own if I received that patient with a
flu and I took a sledgehammer I was like
why are you not getting better do you
think that patient will get better no
you are weakening him you are making him
worse
Israel did not just like weaken the body
of Palestinians making them unable to
get rid of hate and radicalism they have
openly bolstered about helping and
giving money to the same terrorist
organization so I agree I think
Netanyahu is complicit in keeping Hamas
in power because it suited him
politically yes and I think you can't
get away from that yes uh there's no
question of that but there's also no
question that the Israeli government LED
currently by him has to stop Hamas from
perpetrating another terror attack and
again it comes down to this question
what do they do to get rid of Hamas if
it's not what they're doing I don't know
but like as an Israeli citizen listening
to this how come that my prime minister
bragging about giving money to the
terrorist group that he is using right
now to eradicate a whole group of people
and yet using them as an excuse isn't
that weird this is like this is like
Tony Blair being like found like giving
money to alqaeda or Isis and then going
to fight them how does this work how
does this work I agree how does this
work I agree with so yeah it's a
terrorist attack and Israel is funding
them I mean this is the this is in the
words of Benjamin he is this is the
thing about Benjamin he brags about that
stuff so this is a circular
question hamus is to
blame who created Hamas who's helping
them and who is allowing for an
environment for that kind of hate and
and and and destruction of Jewish people
to to to Aspire and I think is there's
something very important to the Western
audience here they think that Israel is
a small tiny country between a hostile
Arab countries the biggest military
power in the in the Arab world is Egypt
they have a peace treaty their neighbors
Jordan they have a peace treaty Saudi
Arabia Emirates either like have like
full rship or like on the way of
normalization the only people that even
Syria Syria is not like even like did
launch like a single bullet the only two
crutches that that that is is likeah and
Hamas a few militant thousands of milit
s is that really formed an existential
like threat especially if I know that
over 13 years only 69 Israelis were
killed I would say I would say is that
an is that that would that really wipe
out Israel is that is Israel that weak I
think if you have two groups of people
who are ideologically wedded to your D
destruction as a state and as a populace
and you're constantly firing Rockets as
Hass have done for over a decade now
then that cannot be acceptable you have
to stop that right these are terrorists
who've now shown on October the 7th
their true colors they don't just talk
about wanting to kill all Jewish people
they are going to do it if they get the
chance so I don't believe Hamas can
possibly stay in any position of
authority in Gaza I think that would be
ruinous for not just the people of Gaza
but also for Israelis so if you're going
to get rid of them which many people
think on both sides is inevitable and
should happen as a consequence of what
they did the big question is how do you
do that and I don't know any other way
other than the way Israel is currently
doing hence my personal moral quandry
about this so if a terorist takes over
the Empire State instead of taking him
out we bomb the whole empire state well
that's the question isn't it proportion
that is not even a question that was not
even a question because that would be
ridiculous talk about you talk about the
normalization of the region I mean the
theory that I most buy into supported by
recent I think Wall Street Journal
reporting the hundreds of Hamas
terrorists had gone to Iran for training
before this attack it obviously been
very carefully organized and so that is
I think highly likely but if you're Iran
and you're looking at all this
normalization and you're looking at
Saudi Arabia being next this is your
worst nightmare so a perfect time to
commit an atrocity like this through
your proxy of Hamas again I'm not a
political expert to know what is the
background but let me tell you a likely
theory is Hamas justifi is all of the
horrible conditions that Palestinians
are living in is that a justification
for Hamas doing what they did in October
good do you think so of course not right
so we're agreed no of course so let me
ask you the question a different way
there is no justification what Israel is
doing now no Hamas no terrorist attack
justifies this because you have been
there
you have been there you have stood
against the Iraq war that is too much
you are killing a whole population
here's the difference I didn't stand
against them for that reason I stood
against the Iraq War because I did not
believe we had seen evidence that Saddam
Hussein had weapons of mass destruction
so we were fighting a war against a
country and a despotic leader which had
nothing to do with 9111 as they were
trying to claim it was actually a lie
perpetrated on the world and the
consequences were disaster a million
people died I mean over 150 British
troops died my brother served in Iraq
and could have been one of them you know
the whole thing was a fiasco a deadly
Fiasco led to the rise of Isis and all
the hell that came with that so you know
I yes absolutely I fought that campaign
against that war and I wish I'd been
successful but the singular difference
here is no one is disputing least of all
the Hamas themselves that they
perpetrated this attack and I believe
Israel has a fundamental right right and
a duty to defend its people from them
doing it again so if we can agree on
that as a principle of a country that's
had that kind of attack and how you deal
with it the question then becomes how do
you eradicate the people who did it and
I just think given the intense nature of
the way the population exist in Gaza
very very large numbers of people in
confined places and that is in itself
unacceptable and I will agree with you
about all of that and that has to be
fixed longer term but actually if Hamas
are everywhere there amongst these
people I just don't see any alternative
to what they're doing and I'm very happy
to consider one but I don't think you
have one either so so if if the Iraqis
were actually there was evidence that
they were behind 911 would that still be
okay to we have a parallel which is
Afghanistan and in fact I would say but
that raises a different question so was
the Afghanistan war just I believe it
was in a way that Iraq wasn't I believe
that Afghanistan was harboring
terrorists Al-Qaeda we know that they
were training there we know the Taliban
were were there and we went in we
launched this war it goes on and on and
on huge Bloodshed on both sides and in
the end after a ridiculous overnight
pull out by America and President Biden
the Taliban are back in charge and W
waging the same kind of medieval rule
they waged before all this so you got
two things was it Justified to strike
back at Afghanistan for harboring
Al-Qaeda I would say yes was the did the
means in the end justify the war You
could argue no actually because actually
you ended up with the Taliban back in
charge so they're two different things
and it may well be here by the way as
I've said that if Israel pursues this
ground Invasion it backfires horribly it
leads to a much wider conflict involving
many other people possibly including
Iran directly and it could be a
horrendous escalation and a massive war
raging through the whole Reg region and
that is my fear about it but I come back
to the central point of
justification and I'm really struggling
to see what else Israel is supposed to
do to get rid of Hamas and if you've got
an
alternative let hear it I do Pierce this
is never about Hames believe me it is
never about Hames if somebody tells you
who they are
listen Israel has been telling the word
all the time they need to clear the Gaza
STP into Egypt you think that's always
been the plan always there I mean they
have said it they have said it many
times why does why does Egypt take them
and do you think when Egypt takes them
do you think they go back no never and
then when they're done with Gaza they
will go back to the West Bank they will
kind of like build the settlements
around them and then until they push
them into Jordan because that is the
plan they have talken not just beenin
now everybody so like there's no state
two states it is one state and is for
the Jews I don't think he believes in
the two states solution nobody believes
in a two- State solution it is one state
but nor do Hamas obviously and they're
the ruling Authority in Gaza they they
don't you see what you're comparing it's
a militant group it's a small militant
group but they is Israel as a nation
they are the elected political
leadership they were elected in 2006 and
50% of the people in Gaza right now are
under the age of 16 they were not even
born I understand yeah like all right so
so B let's all right let's agree about
that but that's the circle it's circular
h h h h I know but okay let's let's move
forward oh yeah let let's assume somehow
we get to a place possibly at the
instigation of countries like Saudi
Arabia and others getting directly
involved where you get to a place where
Hamas are removed and I don't quite see
how that happens without enormous
further Bloodshed but let's assume they
get removed let's assume that Netanyahu
is removed from office which I think is
highly likely just from the fury of his
own people about what they see as the
defensive and security failings plus his
attack on the Supreme Court already
causing huge polarization let's assume
we get new leadership in both
places could there still be peace could
there still be a two-state solution it
can never happen no because Israel have
already shown its it's not about
Netanyahu it is the policy of Israel not
to give the Palestinian their seat it
has always been there but what if you
find leadership understand you will not
but why why are you so you will not why
do you think so because Israel has been
tell you know but then would say the
same about the other side and I remember
who has the power let me okay let me
give you a parallel in his book let me
give you a parallel let me give you a
parallel Northern iseland okay Northern
Ireland appeared to be completely
intractable with the IRA and the
loyalist paramilitaries trying to kill
each other in the Ira's case trying to
kill uh British people as well U because
they they did not want this to go the
way that people wanted it to go go and
ultimately we got to peace because we
found leaders who actually had the
courage the moral courage to get in the
room with the people that were trying to
kill them and to do a deal I don't think
you can do that with Hamas think they're
on a different schedle to go to the IRA
but we did have a seemingly intractable
Place riddled with violence okay on both
sides and eventually we got peace do you
not see there's any chance of doing that
here no not with Israel or
after he left office he wrote in his
book The problem with the Palestinian
Israeli conflict is that that one side
is extremely powerful and one side is
extremely weak there is absolutely
nothing to oblige that strong side to
give anything all over the years Israel
showed you many times that they are not
interested in peace leave Gaza forget
Hamas for a second the West Bank what
have they been doing in the West Bank
the illegal settlements did not stop a
single day they are completely yeah yeah
yeah but but but the thing but you see
what they're doing in the West Bank
right now they are creating little Gaza
they are creating little Gaza yeah and
until they like squeeze them there was
there it's completely wrong there is a
hilarious documentary called The Wanted
18 it is like an Israeli Palestinian
co-production and it tells about the
incredible story about the residence of
bahur it's a Palestinian town next to
the na and uh they said they don't want
to depend on the milk coming from the
kaputs so they bought 18 cows 18 cows
and they didn't know how to milk the
cows or have a a cow farm so so they
were like engineers and and and doctors
they sent people to kind of like to
learn how to do the farm so they bought
the cows and they started to produce
milk and they started to sell the milk
to The Villages the Israeli authorities
were not very comfortable so one day the
military government came in us like
those cows and I quote constitutes an
exis threat to the National Security of
the state of Israel you need to get rid
of them and the movie goes about like
the hilarious attempts of hiding those
cows between The Butchers and the houses
and in one scene that a cow is actually
running and the the Israeli soldiers are
like running behind it and they corner
it and they corner it and they're about
to kill it you know what did the cow
say he didn't fall for this cows don't
speak yeah but you know it actually said
something you know what did it say it
said but
anyways but you see this is the
ideology of the
Israeli ruling part they are not
interested they're not even allowing you
to get your own cows I mean this I want
to discuss something that is very
important because we have been talking
about Israel being a democratic State a
secular state for all of his citizens
including its Arab residents right wrong
wrong wrong wrong 2018 there was a
resolution that was offered in the KET
that say that Israel should be be a
state for all of its CI that seems basic
right that resolution was not even
allowed to be
discussed like why and the and the
rebuttal was Israel being the state of
all of its citizen would threaten the
character of the Jewish
State there is I have a friend of mine
his name is Andrew he's Palestinian
Christian they do exist and uh his
family comes from a town called
t as many Palestinian Town these were
like you know being had another Israel
town called Ka kafar Rin it is a left
cleaning town they voted against n by
70% and they announced an auction to
sell houses and then they noticed that
most of the the the applicants were
Palestinians they canel the auction why
because in each Jewish town there is
something called admission committee
that can decide who can live in this
town sounds like Jim Crow for me and
then they cancel and you know you know
what they say in the reason they say
kafar Rim welcomes all citizens of
Israel despite the race gender or
color however the major uh the majority
of the town would like to preserve the
character of the town as being Jewish
Zionist and secular how does this go
together secular and jewi aside you know
and this brings me to this picture this
is a very famous picture you know
remember this picture I'm sure you've
seen it yeah this for the people who
don't know this from uh St Augustine
Florida 18th of June
1964 this was a white only motel and
these are these are black activists who
wanted to defy the law and jump into the
H this guy he's the only Hotel his name
is James Brook and he was pouring acid
to scare them out of the
hotel his neighbor said that James Brook
was a victim because he was just
following the law and you know what
James Brook said he said it's not like I
don't like black people I just don't
like them in my swimming pools now if an
official said that wouldn't you say that
this town has kind of a systemic racism
yes this was this quote was not said by
James Brook it was said by donon the
head of the Galilean municipality when
he said I don't like Arabs I don't just
like them in my swimming pools the town
of nazarit elite 2010 the Arab
Christians in the town they requested to
set up the Christmas tree next to
another this is the birth right birth
place of Jesus and you know what they
says we cannot have it because because
non religious n Jewish symbolist would
offend Jewish res but this comes back to
what you were saying at the start which
is about the hate on both sides no no no
I'm not talking about the I'm talking
about this shining example that Israel W
tell the bo that we are like the western
or we are secular I don't know if you
know this but they're not just like
secular like RAC against their own Arab
I'm talking about like Arabs with
Palestinian with Israeli identity I'm
talking about them being even racist
against their own people 1950 Yemen's
immigrants that came from Yemen and they
were in the transition Camp waiting to
be transformed into Israel their kids
were taken away from them and given to
White Ashkenazi Jews because they were
not white enough but Bon what would
happen if a Jewish person went to Gaza
how can why would they go to Gaza and
exactly even I wouldn't go to Gaza
exactly that's my point yeah it's a
dystopia who but like but I'm just it's
not just raising points about Israel
making out that somehow there is bad or
worse but what's going on H has red over
the Palestinians in the most impressive
way imagable absolutely but you know
what Hamas never claimed that they are
the only democracy in the in the in the
region they never claimed that they are
secular they never said that they adopt
Western CH and they definitely
definitely they did not use that lie in
order to carp a whole country now here I
I want to say one example and I'm going
to leave all right Israel you think that
Israel will like by the way the whole
thing about the Y children you can find
it in New York Times it's called like
the the Lost Children of Israel the
Forgotten uh but even when Ethiopian
people were immigrated to Israel
Ethiopian
Jews women then Report 2013 that's not
like 50 years ago they reported that
they were given against their consent
and without their knowledge
contraceptive shots so they wouldn't
reproduce because they are the wrong
color Israel is is a
racist apartheid country that is
projecting this shiny example of
secularism and democracy for the people
so people can accept whatever they do
because they look at Palestinians as
lesser people this is the whole point
this is the whole point and I would like
to quote Wiston Churchill mhm he had a
quote that say I don't believe that we
have made a great wrong to the red IND
Indians of America or the black people
of Australia because they were replaced
by a higher race a stronger race a more
World wisely race this is this is why
Queen R is criticizing the W this is why
we here said like where are your values
because this is the Crux of the problem
it's not Hamas it's not Palestine it is
people looking at us as lesser human
beings I and I don't dispute the
characterization that a lot of the
Israel Administration look upon
Palestinians as lesser people otherwise
they wouldn't they even look atan Jews
and Y Jews Like Les I wouldn't dispute
that um I want to quote you to end this
no why would you end this don't end this
we'll be talking for two hours why not
at some point amazing time we do another
interview well this one goes big um I
think this is a neat way to end it he
said I actually believe there is a
middle ground between everybody and they
can meet I direct my criticism for the
extreme of each one of them that was you
Asam you m i I agree with that but I
don't share your view there can never be
peace in this region I I think they
can't be with the current leadership
structures in both countries or both
places but I definitely think you've got
to be optimistic about peace you just
need to find people for it hope I hope
so but the reason
listen I refuse to come on my on your
show when you're producer first called
me for the first
interview because I was scared I was
afraid for me that was a career
suicide because and and I have I'm talk
this is even important because you are
someone who's always talked about like
against cancel about like talking
speaking your mind out speaking your
mind out I left Egypt and I came to
America the land of the free the home of
the brave but I didn't know that there
was a fine print said that you cannot
speak about Israel I have issu with that
Israel is a foreign country their allies
good think about
Israel how many people lost their jobs
even
B she she by the way she hasn't lost her
job no no but she talked about death
threats she's talking about like being
silenced by B is with she's Palestinian
and you know who else sisters I love the
they are with us anyway so I know them
both are very nice yeah but but the
thing is if if you are that high and you
cannot speak about it and it's not about
it's you can just have to yeah you can I
mean I've spoken out about these issues
and you get shot at not literally but
metaphorically all day long on social
media that shouldn't stop people from
doing it I'm just like wondering as an
as an American yeah but like I I'm doing
now because like the first interview
went well I'm doing that because I want
people to see that you can really speak
up and not just get canceled but get
rewarded my career is going fine yeah
it's great because I want people to have
the courage why are there should be no
limits I'm I'm I'm kind of like so so
confused as an American citizen why
every American president cand a
presidential candidate have to go and
kiss the hand and bend the knees to
APAC this is a Lobby that works for a
foreign country interest why don't we
have like a Lobby for Saudi Arabia at is
they giving us more money you know the
great thing you can say that here yes
you couldn't say in Egypt that's why
you're living here yes but again a lot
of people feel the burn the heat
whenever but if I was an American I'd be
going all right bassim all right we'll
take the criticism because you can do
that in this country and I'm happy when
you criticize the government in your own
country yeah they drove you out yes and
that's why I came to America to play The
White Man's game to actually to to to
pass this acquired white privilege to my
children but the problem not just a
country of white people but but here's
the problem and the white man's game the
the game in America is not a white man's
game it's a game that actually has a
democracy and believes in Freedom of
spee dog whistles everywh you're not
going to be put in jail for this
interview or I can lose my career and I
can lose jobs and you know that you
could in Egypt you could no here you can
in Egypt they arrested you here you can
and they threatened you and you would
have probably ended up in prison or dead
here a lot of people lost their jobs
because they spoke up it depends what
they say of course but again if you're
Kye West and you spew anti-semitic G I'm
to I will never adopt that kind of point
of view but the thing is there is dog
whistles everywhere as I told you at the
beginning you cannot just say it's like
anti
like I mean now the how come that the
Palestinian flag is outload by the way
it's outload in Israel if you raise the
a you go to jail and now they're saying
like the Palestinian flag is a pramas no
it's not a pramas you know I was in I
was doing a comedy show in Arizona and a
guy was like wearing like a cof like a
scarf and I took it and and I'm not like
in Hyperbole and like wearing symbols
but I just WR it because like why are we
are we going to Outlook colors and flags
that is that that is abs
that is not right I don't I agree I
don't think you should but you should
certainly Outlaw Hamas regard they're
already Outlaw I mean I'm not supporting
I'm okay okay but the people with the
power the people who supposedly have the
and you should by the way I will say
this you should be able to criticize
Israeli government without being accused
of being anti-semitic I have in this
interview repeatedly and I'm not
anti-semitic I just have a problem with
all of what the Israeli government's
been doing and I have a problem with how
any criticism to Israel by some circles
here are considered anti-semite this is
not fair but a lot of the people doing
it are actually anti-semitic yes but
also a lot of zionists are against
Israel that they hate the Jews you know
it it it we've discussed that I want to
on happy but before I want to just like
say two words about the media which is
okay please
sure uh Mr zlot the Palestinian ambass
that you have this guy lost six members
of his family in an Israeli stru
M and when he went on like some British
news thing he sat down and and and and
and the lady told him like we are very
sorry for personal I'm sure you don't
condem the killing of Israeli civilians
what in the same moment there's another
girl like called diara Aid she was like
on Sky News and and the girl was like
crying like I lost 30 members of my
family 17 of them I lost my best friend
and then what do you think would happen
is I forget about empathy a lot of
people what about manners well I think
you have to start I've said this
repeatedly you have to start from a
place of humanity you have to look at
what happened on October the 7th and
feel utterly outraged and disgusted for
the loss of human life and you also have
to feel that for what's happening in
Gaza to innocent people and if you don't
if you can't feel both for both sets of
people both sets of innocent people
being killed if you can't feel a sense
of of Despair and horror over their
death you don't have any Humanity
believe me Pierce believe me Pierce it's
not really about that there's a deep
sentiment in the Middle East in Arabs
that the West do not look at us as
equals well you know what so what I did
I went to the machines yeah and I asked
Chad gbt simple
questions do Israelis deserve to be free
and you know what they tell me yes
Israelis deserve the right like any
other people and then I asked the same
question to palestin Ians deserve to be
free and you know what they tell me it
is complex it is a sensitive issue well
it's not complex it's not sensitive the
Palestinian people should be free yeah
but even the maches be finished and they
should have exactly the same rights to
freedom and freedom of expression and a
way to lead their lives and to water and
to power and to Internet that Israelis
have and we have here in America and we
have back in my home country of the UK
and I want that for the Palestinian
people we've got to end it there okay
mainly because I've worked up a hell of
a in 2 hours of interview and you have
brought your
wife's so tell me again how I do this
okay so basically take a piece of this
put it in the olive oil yes which is
from the West Bank yeah from the west
bank and then a little bit of this yes
are that yes yes this is like amazing
oil coming from the Olive Tree uh this
is come from the West Bank since 1967
Israel have actually uprooted 800,000
Olive Tree just two that is absolutely
Ely delicious please thank your wife for
me thank wish her all the best and her
family particularly those who are
obviously in Gaza it's been great to see
you thank you so much in America let's
do it again let's do it again let's keep
talking I honestly think the way through
this is people keep talking yes good to
see thank you so
much